>> LET ME CLARIFY.
THE TWO OF THEM ARE BACKING OFF
OF WAR AND I SEE TRUMP PROVOKING
WAR.
>> Sean: JOINING US WITH
REACTION, EDITOR AT LARGE AT
THE DailyMail.com,
PIERS MORGAN.
DIDN'T WE COMPETE AGAINST EACH
OTHER?
WEREN'T WE ENEMIES?
WE WERE ALWAYS FINE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> GREAT TO BE BACK ON THE SHOW.
YOU ARE ALWAYS CHARMING IN
VICTORY I HAVE TO SAY.
>> Sean: CHARMING NOTHING.
IT WAS NEVER PERSONAL.
100,000 OTHER CHANNELS.
I AM TRYING TO COMPETE AGAINST
ALL OF THEM.
PANICKING AND FISHING.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE EVER
FOUND ANYTHING RELATED TO
COLLUSION, AND THEY JUST KEEPS
BRINGING OFF INTO OTHER --
HE IS AN ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO FIRE
JAMES COMEY.
IT'S ACTUALLY SCARY IN TERMS OF
WHAT I BELIEVE IS A FISHING
EXPEDITION, AND I THINK YOU
AGREE WITH THAT.
>> I DO, AND ACTUALLY I FIND IT
EXTRAORDINARY THAT JAMES COMEY,
A FORMER BOSS AT THE FBI, IS
ABLE TO WRITE A SORT OF TELL-ALL
BOOK RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
THIS WOULDN'T HAPPEN IN MANY
OTHER COUNTRIES.
YOU WOULDN'T BE ALLOWED TO DO
THIS.
PEDDLING ALL SORTS OF LURID AND
RIDICULOUS DETAILS TO THE WORLD
RIDICULOUS DETAILS TO THE WORLD.
IT MAKES ME THINK THIS.
DONALD TRUMP FIRED HIM BECAUSE
HE DIDN'T TRUST HIM.
HE WAS RIGHT, WASN'T HE?
WHEN YOU READ THIS STUFF POURING
OUT OF HIS BOOKS, DONALD TRUMP
WAS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT NOT TO
TRUST JAMES COMEY.
IN RELATION TO THE WIDER MUELLER
PROBE, I THINK WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE IS THAT THEY TRIED TO GET
THE PROOF ON RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
THEY WANTED TO PROVE THE WORLD
THAT DONALD TRUMP COLLABORATED
WITH THE RUSSIANS TO FIX THE
ELECTION.
THAT'S WHY HE WON.
NO OTHER REASON.
HAS TO BE THAT.
SO FAR, THEY HAVE SINGULARLY
FAILED TO ESTABLISH IT.
NOW THEY ARE MOVING THE GOAL
POSTS.